It's the only way
to know for sure.
♪
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
TODAY SLAPPING TARIFFS ON
STEEL AND ALUMINUM IMPORTS.
THE TARIFFS APPLY TO ALL
COUNTRIES EXCEPT MEXICO AND
CANADA WHILE THEY
RENEGOTIATE NAFTA WITH US.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THE
U.S. NOW IMPORTS FOUR TIMES
AS MUCH STEEL AS IT EXPORTS.
>> THE AMERICAN
STEEL-ALUMINUM INDUSTRY HAS
BEEN RAVAGED BY AGGRESSIVE
FOREIGN TRADE PRACTICE HE
FOREIGN TRADE PATCTICE HE
FOREIGN TRADE PATROICE HE
FOREIGN TRADE PATROLCE HE
FOREIGN TRADE PATROL C HE
FOREIGN TRADE PATROL CARE
FOREIGN TRADE PATROL CAR PRACTIC
FOREIGN TRADE PATROL CAR PRACTIS
FOREIGN TRADE PATROL CAR PRACTII
FOREIGN TRADE PATROL CAR PRACTI'
FOREIGN TRADE PATROL CAR PRACTIS
REALLY AN ASSAULT ON OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY KNOW BETTER THAN
ANYBODY U IT'S A PROCESS
CALLED DUMPING.
THEY DROVE OUR PLANTS AND
FACTORIES OUT OF BUSINESS.
>> Laura: DUSTY STEPHENS
ATTENDED THE SIGNING
CEREMONY IN THE WROTE VET
ROOM TODAY.
IS HE SUPERINTENDENT AT
CENTURY ALUMINUM POT LINE
AND HE JOINS TO US DISCUSS
WHAT THIS MOVE IS GOING TO
MEAN TO HIS COMPANY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TALK TO
PEOPLE THAT ARE REALLY IN
THE BUSINESS INSTEAD OF
PUNDITS AND ANALYSTS.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
FIELD SO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
HECK WAS GOING ON.
GREAT TO SEE THAT EVENT
TODAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Laura: YOU GOT UP AND
SPOKE.
THE PRESIDENT SIGNALED OUT
CENTURY ALUMINUM BECAUSE OF
THE MILITARY GRADE MATERIALS
THAT YOU GUYS PRODUCE.
WHAT DOES THIS POLICY MEAN
FOR YOUR KENTUCKY OPERATION?
>> SO RIGHT NOW WE ARE
RUNNING AT 40% CAPACITY.
TWO YEARS AGO WE HAD TO SHUT
DOWN 60% OF OUR CAPACITY DUE
TO THE DOWNTURN IN THE
MARKET.
WITH THE TARIFFS PUT IN
PLACE TODAY WE ARE GOING TO
GET BACK THAT 60%.
WE ARE GOING TO INVEST
$100 MILLION TO GET BACK
THAT MILITARY GRADE
ALUMINUM.
>> Laura: $100 MILLION WILL
MEAN HOW MANY JOBS?
>> IT WILL BE OVER 300 JOBS.
>> Laura: HOW IMPORTANT IS
THAT TO THIS KENTUCKY
COMMUNITY?
>> IT'S HUGE.
IT'S HUGE.
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE
300 JOBS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
INTRODUCE INTO THE
COMMUNITY, AND THAT'S GREAT.
THE BIGGEST ISSUE HERE IS WE
ARE GOING TO PRESERVE THAT
PLANT.
WE HAVE 200 PLUS EMPLOYEES
HERE NOW.
WITHOUT THESE TARIFFS WE
WOULD LOSE THOSE JOBS AS
WELL.
IN REALITY WE ARE SAVING
OVER 500 JOBS.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU HEAR
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THIS
FROM WASHINGTON OR NEW YORK
MOST OF THEM NEVER BEEN IN A
MANUFACTURING PLANT.
THEY HAVE NEVER STEPPED FOOT
IN ONE.
THEY HAVE DON'T KNOW PEOPLE
LIKE YOU.
THEY DON'T KNOW PEOPLE LIKE
YOU, THE COMMUNITY.
THESE JOBS ARE NEVER COMING
BACK.
TIME TO MOVE ON TO 21st
CENTURY ECONOMY.
IT'S ALL ROBOTS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> I WISH THEY COULD WALK IN
MY SHOES.
I HAVE SEEN A LOT IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
I HAVE SEEN MY FRIENDS GO
OUT THE DOOR NOT KNOWING IF
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE A JOB
THE NEXT DAY.
I HAVE SEEN MY FAMILY HAS
BEEN DIRECTED AFFECTED BY
IT.
MY FATHER WORKED AT THAT
SMELTER 40 YEARS.
HE RETIRED EARLY SO ANOTHER
GUY COULD KEEP HIS JOB.
MY BROTHER, HE WAS LAID OFF
DURING THE DOWNTURN.
HE DIDN'T COME BACK TO WORK.
THIS IS DIRECTLY AFFECTED
OUR FAMILY.
NOT ONLY OURS BUT EVERY --
THERE IS OVER 300 OTHER
FAMILIES THAT WERE AFFECTED
BY THIS DOWNTURN AND NOW THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
GIVEN IT BACK TO US.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE OTHER
GENTLEMEN WHO WAS IN THE
ROOSEVELT ROOM TODAY, I
GUESS WE DO NOT HAVE THE
SOUND BITE.
IT WAS SO COMPELLING.
HE IS FROM THE UNION.
>> YES.
>> Laura: HE GOT UP AND HE
SAID UNTIL YOU SEE THE LOOK
OF A FATHER LOOKING INTO THE
EYES OF HIS SON AND THE
SADNESS OF YOU CAN'T PROVIDE
FOR YOUR FAMILY.
YOU HAVE SIX KIDS.
HIS FATHER AND HIS FAMILY
HAD SIX KIDS.
HE SAID I WILL NEVER FORGET
THAT DAY.
>> YOU WON'T.
>> Laura: HERE HE IS
SPEAKING NOW.
YOU COULD NEVER FORGET THAT
DAY.
HE SAID THAT EMOTION, WHAT
THAT DOES TO A FAMILY IS
JUST DEVASTATING.
>> AND IT IS.
IT IS.
HAVING TO GO HOME AND SEE MY
BROTHER TORE UP BECAUSE HE
HAS A LITTLE ONE AT HOME.
HE KNOWS HE CAN'T PROVIDE
FOR HER.
HE KNOWS HE IS NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO PAY HIS BILLS
MONTH TO MONTH AND SEEING
THAT DAY IN AND DAY OUT
STRUGGLE IT'S TOUGH.
>> Laura: DID YOU FEEL LIKE
A POLITICIAN BEFORE TRUMP
CAME ALONG REALLY UNDERSTOOD
THIS COMMUNITY, REALLY GOT
THE CORE OF AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS TO NATIONAL
SECURITY AND TO OUR ECONOMIC
VITALITY.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
SOMETHING IN PLACE FOR OVER
TWO YEARS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IN
THE LAST, WHAT, 14 SOME ODD
MONTHS HAS PUT THIS IN PLACE
AND GOT THIS BALL ROLLING
FOR US.
SO THIS IS GREAT.
NOT ONLY FOR THE ALUMINUM
INDUSTRY.
>> Laura: THE DUMPING FROM
CHINA AND FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES HAS DEPRESSED THE
PRICE.
AMERICAN COMPANIES CAN'T
COMPETE.
BUT WHAT THE CRITICS OF
THESE TARIFFS SAY IS ALL THE
PRODUCTS WE MAKE ARE GOING
TO BE A LOT MORE EXPENSIVE
NOW.
YOU ARE GOING TO BE HURTING
THE MOM AND POP CONSUMERS TO
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> WE HAVE A PREMIUM PRODUCT
THAT NOBODY ELSE IN THE
WORLD CAN PRODUCE.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST GRADE
ALUMINUM NUT WORLD.
AND IT GOES TO OUR MILITARY
AND OUR AEROSPACE.
WITHOUT THAT, WHERE DO YOU
GET THAT ALUMINUM?
>> Laura: WE DON'T WANT TO
BUY IT FROM CHINA.